in ganz deutschland sind sie unterwegs
die erbenermittler es geht um viel geld
und darum wer erbt dabei kann es jeden
treffen auch ihre familie
stellen sie sich mal selbst vor alles
klingelt jemand bei ihnen an der tür und
sagt ich vermittelt ihnen ein größeres
vermögen sie haben für den betreffenden
ist das wie tausendundeine nacht also so
ein goldregen mit dem mann überhaupt
nicht gerechnet hat doch beim erben geht
es sehr ungleich zu manche erben viel
und können es kaum glauben
[Musik]
andere dagegen erben nur wenig wir haben
möchte bitteschön sofort anziehen wird
nicht mal mehr die kleiderkammer und
wieder andere haben pech und erben gar
nichts ich habe keine chance
ich war immer anteilig an beim erben
kommen die traurigsten schicksale zum
vorschein
ich frage mich wie man so leben kann und
meist geht es dabei vor allem um eines
die familie
familie ist meistens das schlimmste
erwartet irrt
[Musik]
andré ulrich ist erbenermittler wenn ein
mensch stirbt und es wieder nachkommen
noch ein testament gibt dann beginnt
seine suche nach möglichen erben das
vermögen des mannes der früher
angesehenes mitglied dieses tennisclubs
war ein gericht hat röhrig beauftragt
nach angehörigen zu forschen dafür muss
er das leben des verstorbenen
rekonstruieren der regel ist dass eine
person diese einnahmen war die
verstorben ist keine kinder hinterlassen
keine geschwister die eltern schon lange
tot und dann versuchen wir
nachzuvollziehen wer als er aber in
frage kommt die leidenschaft des mannes
führte ulrich hierher in den klub viele
freunde häuser in frankreich so war wohl
sein leben
doch sein tod war einsam ohne familie
ohne nachkommen
soll sehr verwirrt gewesen sein hatte
aber einen bezug zu frankreich und in
den akten konnte ich lesen dass es
eventuell ein außerirdisches kind
gegeben haben soll
was ich natürlich dringend suche wenn
mir jemand hinweise geben würde auf
dieses kind dann hätte ich meine andré
ulrich will dieser spur folgen er hofft
dass ehemalige tennis freunde mehr
wissen
seine arbeit ähnelt der eines detektivs
er darf nicht locker lassen muss
indizien sammeln einen fall lösen
[Applaus]
zweimal verheiratet alle ehefrauen tod
und keine geschwister aus königsberg wie
so oft gestaltet sich die suche 10
doch dann
endlich jemand der den toten besser
kannte
er war sehr elegant nur im blazer
krawatte und immer schick und die frau
auch immer elegant immer schick und
immer den ganzen tollen schmuck um
doch die letzten jahre des verstorbenen
waren weniger glamourös dement geworden
vegetierte er im heim vor sich hin
vielleicht ist das mit dem
außerehelichen kind in dieser zeit
gewesen wo das nicht mehr so ganz alles
stimmig war an seinem leben das ist
deswegen kann ich das nicht da kann ich
ja ist ja nicht mehr alleine weggegangen
ja ja aber ich meine dass er sich das
vielleicht ganz recht konstruiert sehr
an frankreich ging und danach das
vielleicht überlegt aber ich hatte keine
kinder vielleicht da ich hatte
vielleicht doch irgendwann mal was
vielleicht ist ja ein kind daraus
entstanden oder so dass das irgendwie so
ich weiß es nicht so ist auch nicht also
wenn denken es ist also es kann ja auch
in berlin wieder da will ich nicht sagen
also ich weiß nicht wie er seine
freizeit verbrachte wem hatte der mann
etwas erzählt wir stand ihm in den
letzten jahren von wem könnte ullrich
etwas erfahren
also da gibt es hier in berlin das war
eine ärztin frau dr
und diese frau doktor die war die ärztin
schon gegen beiden und die wird
vielleicht was wissen
zwei telefonnummern nimmt röhrig mit
keine schlechte ausbeute
wenn das eine spur ist erich nachgehe
und wenn sich daraus ergeben würde
wer perfekt
die deutschen vererben jedes jahr ein
riesiges vermögen bis zu 400 milliarden
euro
das berliner büro der erbenermittler
arbeitet ullrich in einem fall dann
zeichnet er nach und nach einen
stammbaum der familie oft über jahre
der kann dann schon mal größer werden
[Musik]
ich schätze mal dass das vielleicht vier
meter sind dass zwischendurch immer
wieder aufgetrennt zusammengeklebt denn
doch noch ich ein kind gefunden habe was
dazwischen kommt andré ulrich ist
studierter historiker seine arbeit führt
ihn in die vergangenheit und rund um die
welt
das ist für mich auch jedes mal spannend
wo die reise hingeht wo man letztendlich
die erben findet in deutschland in
amerika südamerika australien jetzt
hatte ich eine familie dar ich zwei
erben in indien gefunden
herr ulrich könnten sie gerade mal mit
zu mir rüber kommen ja weil es droht ein
neuer fall ein auftrag für die erben
ermittler
[Musik]
wir haben einen neuen fall rein bekommen
wir haben schon ein paar fakten
erblasser 63 verheiratet seine ehefrau
98 verstorben und der gemeinsame sohn
ist bei der geburt bereits verstorben
weitere kinder sind nicht da und die
mutter des erblassers ist bereits 1933
verstorben
und jetzt müsste dieser fall weiter
ermittelt werden ich darf ihnen den
übergeben
rückfragen sind können wir dann gerne
nochmal drüber sprechen dann viel erfolg
bei der ermittlung banker andré ulrich
macht sich sofort an die arbeit findet
er einen erben bekommt seine firma rund
ein drittel des vermögens im falle des
verstorbenen herrn könig lohnt dass der
nachlass beläuft sich auf 155.000 euro
und 1 prozent doch dafür muss er erst
mal erfolgreich sein
ansonsten bleiben die erbenermittler auf
ihren kosten sitzen und das erbe geht an
den start
holger siebert ist hier der chef er
arbeitet nicht nur als erbenermittler
sondern auch als anwalt für erbrecht
sein aktueller fall ist ein klassiker
geschwister die sich um ein haus
streiten für seinen mandanten hat holger
siebert die immobilie schätzen lassen
ich denke mal er geht von einem höheren
wert aus bei dieser angelegenheit eher
wird er überrascht sein denn es kommt
wie immer auf die lager an
das ist schon sehr provinziell und weg
vom schuss um es mal salopp zu sagen
also ich denke mal da werden werden die
investoren nicht schlange stehen ab vom
schuss aber eben doch ein zuhause
andreas es hat immer in dem haus in der
brandenburgischen provinz geliebt hier
die mutter und den stiefvater bis zum
tod gepflegt hier will er bleiben
das ist meine heimat das war mein
zuhause und ist momentan also endlich
schade drum weiter verbessert werden
müsste
denn jetzt erheben die zwei leibliche
söhne aus der ersten jedes die vaters
anspruch auf ihren anteil am erbe 30
jahre hatten sie ihren vater kaum
gesehen
das haus kennen sie nicht sich um nichts
kümmern aber erben wollen dann hoffnung
diesen hier wissen anteil pflichtanteil
haben ein recht darauf um die tochter
noch gesetzlich einzuklagen und es hat
mich am meisten
der stiefvater hatte die eigenen söhne
enterbt doch der pflichtanteil steht
ihnen zu so will es das gesetz
andreas es hat nicht viel um seine
stiefbruder auszuzahlen müsste er sein
zuhause verkaufen
im haus ist die zeit stehengeblieben
weil es ist so wie es die eltern
hinterlassen haben
denn eigentlich sollte ein notar
vorbeikommen um den wert der besitztümer
zu schätzen
wegen des streits um den eventuell zu
veräußern und ihren als geschenk
zukommen zu lassen
ich finde ich einen blick jetzt die
kosten nicht noch trauer deswegen war
der notar bis heute nicht da andreas
leben ist ihm geblieben
[Musik]
hier sind 100 elterliche schlafzimmer
dann kommt man nicht hin und immer
wieder diese alte kram ich kenne das ja
schon alles rausgeholt und wurde jänner
hier komplett einziehen
alles nutzen
[Musik]
halberstadt wer möchte bitteschön sofort
anziehen
ja wer hat sich soweit noch an waren wir
irgendwann wechselt man komplett ein
zuviel ist weil er sich auch ewig
einzieht und musik in san martin licht
am tunnel
dennoch hängt er sehr an ihm aus und das
obwohl auch die erinnerungen weniger
glücklich sind
[Musik]
nicht viel schnee an ihr geholfen werden
immer einsatzbereit zu sein und dann
irgendwann jetzt schon mal so darüber
nachdenkt man stumpft ob man sagt man
musste irgendwann los bern wo will man
das nicht absurd
[Musik]
ich sag mal durch den erben wird diese
die ganze familienleben teilweise
auseinander gerissen
noch schlimmer wie vorher eventuell war
und familie ist meistens das schlimmste
erwartet irrt
wenn geschwister untereinander haben das
geht zurück auf irgendwelche ereignisse
die in früher kindheit stattgefunden
haben das ist so ungefähr das
schwierigste was es gibt für einen
anwalt heute wollen andreas s und holger
siebert beratschlagen wie sie in dem
erbstreit zwischen den geschwistern
weiter verfahren wollen das objekt der
begierde wir können beim kleinen
rundgang noch machen das ergebnis noch
mal bronze sich so alle streiten der erb
rechtsanwalt hat den schätzwert des
hauses mitgebracht
doch zunächst bekommt er eine führung
[Musik]
das ist alles so geblieben wie jetzt so
verlassen wurde ja ja so da ist doch
nichts neu neu gemacht waren hat man ja
gesprochen habt ihr eine schweizer
verändert außer man die möbel und er
rückt für andreas es ist nun der moment
der wahrheit gekommen
wir haben mal versucht hier eine wert
größe zu ermitteln was hier diese
liegenschaft angeht es ergibt sich dann
aufgrund der grundstücksfläche ein
reiner grundstücks wert von etwa 34.000
euro nur das nackte grundstück und für
die baulichkeiten die da drauf stehen
aufgrund des zustandes das ist ja jetzt
nicht modernster komisch war die er ist
ein großer reparaturstau hat der makler
gesagt 25.000 euro sodass wir ich sag
jetzt mal wenn wir jetzt mal über einen
ganz dicken daumen gehen
das gesamtobjekt mit etwa 60.000 euro
taxieren könnten also sprich nach abzug
von anderen sämtlichen kosten des nichts
mehr da ja das ist werden wir gleich
noch sehen was noch da sich die
gegenseite seit monaten nicht mehr
meldet entscheiden sich andreas und sein
anwalt dafür die sache auch von ihrer
seite ruhen zu lassen
gesetzlich erlischt der anspruch nach
drei jahren
das hieße aber in konsequenz dass das
damoklesschwert des
pflichtteilsanspruchs während dieser
gesamten verbleibenden rest zeit hier
schwebt noch eineinhalb jahre muss
andreas es ausharren mit ungewissem
ausgang
denn die bruder können sich jederzeit
wieder melden
viele denken nachricht ja wort ich bin
jetzt ruhig meine feste jetzt mehr den
flug als einsehen
[Musik]
währenddessen ist erbenermittler andere
ullrich bei seinen recherchen im fall
könig auf eine sackgasse gestoßen
es gibt auch keine geschwister hermann
ein einzelkind
dann suchen wir quasi von seiner mutter
die geschwister konnte und das
herauszubekommen müssen wir wissen wer
die großeltern war am nächsten tag macht
sich auf den weg ins berliner
landesarchiv dort lagern die akten aller
in berlin jemals getätigten behörden
vorgänger und hoffentlich auch hinweise
auf das leben der großeltern des
verstorbenen herrn könig guten tag ich
bin herr ulrich ich hatte person stand
bücher bestellt er bücher sterbe
geburten ein kläger geschoren
die suche in archiven ist das täglich
brot der erbenermittler andré ulrich
kann sich dennoch kaum etwas
spannenderes vorstellen
er erhofft sich viel von der heutigen
recherche
das ziel ist in der linie könig den
ursprung der familie könig zu finden um
dann dort anzusetzen um weiter zu
recherchieren weil im endeffekt muss ich
meinem stammbaum wieder runter und muss
auf jeden gestoßen
die kinder und deren kindes gymnasien
heute einen erbanteil zusteht
doch die suche nach der familie des
großvaters verläuft ins leere
bei der linie der großmutter dagegen hat
ulrich glück ich habe die heiratsurkunde
der großeltern gefunden
interessant führt nach köniz dort ist
der ursprung der großmutter damaliges
westpreußen nun geht es darum die
geschwister der großmutter zu suchen
deren enkel und urenkel konnten als
erben in frage kommen endlich ein erfolg
mit abstrichen hätte mich mehr darüber
gefreut wenn ihr stehen würde wohnhaft
berlin und nicht gerade kurz weil
cornetz polen ist doch aufwendiger jetzt
muss ich meine polnischen kollegen
bitten dort weiter zu recherchieren
es hätte auch stehen können
in amerika geboren das wäre natürlich
noch fataler gewesen
die suche geht weiter in polen
der bergmann kiez der szenebezirk der
hauptstadt
hierhin hat es sollte den erbenermittler
holger siebert verschlagen
wir sind hier in berlin kreuzberg in der
kreuzbergstraße und das ist ich sage uns
mal ein pulsierendes viertel hier in
berlin sicherlich die immobilien hier
sehr schwer zu erwerben sind
deswegen hat glück wer hier ein haus
erbt
es ist ja in unserem job immer so dass
wir leute ermitteln die von ihrem glück
eben nichts wissen und dann eben zu
völlig überraschenden reichtum kommen
heute trifft er so einen glückspilz die
erben ermittler haben peter lenz zu
einem haus im bergmann kiez verholfen
was hat er gedacht hat sich die erben
ermittler bei ihm meldeten
[Musik]
da würde mich immer verarschen es klingt
absurd da ist es ist schon irgendwo
sowie sowie nicht so wie bei lotterie
wir haben so czech und freunde talents
hat die großtante von die er geerbt hat
nur einmal gesehen
ein gut gehen damit gerade die partie
reich gemacht und jetzt ihn zusammen mit
seinem anwalt betritt er ihre wohnung
zum ersten mal hier zu leben kann sich
peter lenz nicht vorstellen
er will verkaufen ich frage mich wie man
so leben kann also runter vom das noch
fahren sowieso also auf jeden fall
irgendwie macht scheinbar also ich viel
die alte dame war reich aber einsam und
schwierig nach der wende hatte peter
lenz vater versucht die tante aus dem
westen zu besuchen ist aber immer sehr
unhöflich gespeist worden
so nach dem motto kommt hier nur als
sport so ein schmarotzer her und will
hier nur irgendwas dran und der angst
irgendwann tun wie hat die was ich
sowieso ja die frau kann hier die die
freie wahl bestätigt das ist also nicht
[Musik]
weniger von schülern gegeben
die rooney der geschichte nach dem tod
der alten dame erbt gerade die
ungeliebte ost verwandtschaft ihr haus
und ihr vermögen
[Musik]
doch ganz so einfach war das mit dem
erben nicht denn plötzlich meldete
jemand anderes anspruch auf das vermögen
an eine frau behauptete es gäbe ein
handschriftliches testament dass sie als
einzige erbin einsetzt also auf dieser
basis bestand da wohl ein persönlicher
kontakt
die frau zog vor gericht um zu beweisen
dass sie erbberechtigt sei doch das
angebliche testament war nicht
auffindbar
im ergebnis ist diese einmal
vermeintliche testaments erbin damit
nicht durchgedrungen weil sie den
nachweis nicht führen konnte dass es ein
testament mit dem von ihr gewünschten
inhalt überhaupt gegeben hat das
testament blieb verschwunden und so
erbte peter lenz
die frau die geklagt hatte konnte ihren
anspruch nicht beweisen
diese frau ist dorota cayet sie arbeitet
als kellnerin in einem steakhouse dort
lernte sie auch die alte dame kennen mit
all ihren eigenheiten und ihren ritualen
jeden tag kommen und tomaten
später als die frau immer gebrechlicher
wurde brachte ihr dorothea kaje das
essen nach hause
direkt neben dem restaurant zunächst
durfte sie nur bis an die wohnungstüre
kommen wo ich dann ist es das ganze
beziehung entstanden
die alte dame war spürbar einsam und
krank dorota cayet begann sich um sie zu
kümmern sie zu pflegen über jahre jeden
tag
das ging auch zulasten ihres eigenen
familienlebens davon können ihre kinder
berichten
[Musik]
also wir haben auch öfter mit ihr
telefoniert weil hier gehe es ja also
oft nicht und dann hat sie mal gefragt
bewusstsein nahrung mama ich hab schon
so lange nicht mehr gesehen obwohl sie
gestern noch dort gewesen ist
also sie hat sehr oft angerufen geld hat
die alleinerziehende mutter für ihre
arbeit nie bekommen und auch nicht
verlangt aber sie sollte erben
sie hat auch gesagt ich würde sich
absichern
also wir wollten endlich nicht noch zu
notar gehen am nächsten tag ist die alte
dame tod droht ak jetzt sagt es habe ein
handschriftliches testament gegeben doch
das kann niemand finden vor gericht
verliert sie deswegen trotz zeugen ist
kein testament da ich habe keine chance
also nutzen keinen zeugen nutzen nicht
also da bringt nichts wenn es weg ist es
schon versucht was sie versuchen kann
aber muss weiter lesen das ist nur noch
dass sie jetzt nicht auf kosten sitzt
und irgendwie für das gericht oder so
zahlen muss weil das wäre dann wirklich
schwierig für uns aber die
gerichtskosten betragen fast 20.000 euro
[Musik]
zurück im berliner büro der
erbenermittler ich muss ich muss man
unseren kollegen in polen sprechen
andere ulrich wartet noch immer auf
antwort aus polen
er hofft auf neuigkeiten im fall könig
doch dafür muss erst einmal die
verbindung stehen
[Musik]
ich hatte dich ja gebeten dass du in
meinem fall könig nach geschwistern von
der großmutter franziska könig
recherchiert habt ihr da irgendwie was
gefunden
ja so ich habe gestern eine antwort vom
stadt blumberg bekommen also jetzt weiß
ich dass die genossen und ernst meint
ist pikant acht geschwister 8
das ist ja erfreulich da haben wir noch
viele gedanken zu suchen acht
geschwistern also erste kennt dann gibt
es dir dort der erbenermittler bekommt
die namen der geschwister von horst
königs großmutter mit diesen muss er
wieder in die archive findet er lebende
enkel und urenkel hat er endlich seine
erben
ein letztes mal noch möchte droht akut
die wohnung der alten dame besuchen die
sie jahrelang gepflegt hat
die frau von der sie werben sollte und
von der sie dann doch nichts bekam
früher war sie fast jeden tag hier
[Musik]
endlich ich habe viele jahre gemacht
seltsame gefühl habe meine hände
sie saß im sessel hat von singen tot
aufgefundene lachse viel an boden
[Musik]
erinnerungen an den tod der alten dame
aber auch erinnerungen an die tage mit
ihr
[Musik]
ein leben das sie hier alleine
verbrachte
außer wenn büro taca jetzt kam manchmal
kommen nicht wieder hat sie angefangen
zu heulen kenntnis genommen und mir
geschehen
und das ist so ja es ist traurig aber
man kann es enden
sie weiß wie unglaublich ihre geschichte
klingt doch sie ist sich auch ganz
sicher am todestag der alten dame hatte
das handschriftliche testament neben dem
bett gelegen
später war es dann einfach verschwunden
[Musik]
da stehen weil das bin ich alles aber
nicht dass und das war auch diese ganze
zeit das natürlich geht auch nun das
haus die ich mich viele frauen aber das
geht in dieser gewichtigkeit das wird
meine würde
[Musik]
das leben der allein erziehenden mutter
könnte jetzt ein anderes sein
[Musik]
rising wie viel sie geerbt hätte es
wären mit dem barvermögen 3 millionen
euro gewesen
davon hat jetzt die talent zu einem
guten teil bekommen
[Musik]
handel und entschieden vom gericht
schriftlich und auch an die erben
ermittler gingen rund eine halbe million
euro
[Musik]
andré ulrich ist dem fall könig fast am
ziel angelangt während seiner suche ist
ein umfangreicher stammbaum der familie
könig entstanden
[Musik]
viel zeit ist vergangen als ich
angefangen habe ein kunstwerk
er hat die familie des verstorbenen bis
nach polen zurück verfolgt und über die
acht geschwister der großmutter noch
lebende verwandte in deutschland
gefunden die jetzt alle erben
wir haben eine erbengemeinschaft von 11
erben ein erbe ist wolfgang block den
ich in konstanz am bodensee ausfindig
machen konnte was in berlin begann nach
polen führte endet nun ganz im süden von
deutschland in konstanz für diesen
letzten teil der reise macht sich der
chef der erbenermittler holger siebert
selbst auf den weg
was glaubt er warum kümmern sich selbst
vermögende menschen häufig nicht um
ihren nachlass das kernthema ist dass
die meisten menschen dieses thema des
eigenen todes verdrängen
man ist sich zwar von zeit zu zeit
durchaus bewusst dass man das regeln
müsste aber dann verschwindet die idee
auch ganz schnell wieder in der
schublade
tatsächlich versterben 65 bis 75 prozent
der deutschen ohne ein testament zu
hinterlassen und so steht holger siebert
schließlich vor der haustüre von herrn
blog es müssen letzte formalitäten
geklärt werden bevor das erbe endlich
übergeben werden kann
[Musik]
wolfgang block wuchs in berlin auf zog
aber dann in den süden
sie wissen ja um was es geht sie sind ja
glückliche aber geworden und ich bin
heute zu ihnen nach konstanz gekommen
weil da natürlich bis das erbe zugeführt
werden kann also die vermögenswerte noch
einige formalitäten geregelt werden
müssen und das wollte ich heute gern mit
ihnen tun so teuer überraschend so in
der tat überhaupt bescheid gekriegt habe
dass es da eine herbe gibt ja ich kannte
die personen kaum kann die schwach daran
erinnern am alexanderplatz getroffen zu
haben
doch das ist nicht alles im laufe der
ermittlungen kam es auch zu einer
familienzusammenführung
die ich jetzt noch ein bruder
stiefbruder ist es aus lüttich wie
üblich von den 155.000 euro erbte blog
10.600 wenn sie noch fragen haben kommen
wir da gerne darüber sprechen und man
sonst nur die sie bitten das mit datum
zu versehen und zu unterschreiben
der rest geht an die elf anderen erben
und an die erben ermittlern
[Musik]
nochmals herzlichen dank dass das heute
mit dem termin
deutschland-cup rechtsanwalt sind die
sachen ja meistens von
auseinandersetzungen geprägt da hat man
zwar hier und da das erfolgserlebnis
aber da wo sie auf der einen seite den
gewinner haben haben sie immer auf der
anderen seite und verlierer und das ist
hier nicht so hier haben sie eigentlich
immer nur gewinner
und auch die geschichte von dorota cayet
ändert mit einem kleinen sieg das
gericht hat ihr die verfahrenskosten von
fast 20.000 euro erlassen
[Musik]